[Music]
another great opportunity right now is
uh free so i look at the whole software
market as really backwards
okay in which
right now it doesn't matter if you're a
hubspot or canva eventually someone can
just create a me too company and just
undercut you on pricing and what i've
learned is if you can create a software
company that already has a brand that
has a free product and you just make it
really good for free and you just keep
adding more and more to it
a great example of this is photo p so
there's this company called photo p it's
uh
uh we love it photoshop and it's like
they make very little to no money so i
hit up one of my buddies who uh is great
at outreaching and i told him i want
photo fee i offered him 10 million he
said no offered him 20 million he said
no
i can take photo p make it a really good
canva competitor undercut him on pricing
whatever be worth 10 20 40 billion
whatever they are no but i probably can
cashflow that thing to like four or five
million a month in ebitda
right it's like who cares what it sells
for what it's worth
you're saying make it free and you're
saying a cash flow is like a
so what how do you take a
free product in cash like how would you
explain that well he said he said a
canva a canva knockoff
canva knockoff so you make you make
almost 99 of it for free you charge for
one percent but that one percent is
enough where you can drive in the
revenue so you don't ever make as much
as like a canva or like
a mailchimp or a hubspot but hey if you
can make millions a month in profit it's
still good what's your math there so
when what's the calculus when you were
thinking so like let's say photo p
according to similar web has 10 million
uniques a month or something what was
your math
is that right
yeah it is right
we researched it
yeah so like what was your calculus to
get to uh four million and even a month
like what would how many people would
you need to run it and what was the
what's the calculus there
sure so
i can probably get the thing from 10
million visitors i can so let's say i
bought it for 20 right he wouldn't sell
it to me for 20. um i've never
outreached him but i had a buddy
outreach to him for me who just does all
my outreach so let's say i bought it for
20 i'd put another 10 into it so now i'm
out 30 million dollars
i'm really good at growing traffic and i
know i can grow the team to roughly 40
million uniques a month i just have a
i don't know how but for some weird
reason i know traffic really well and
how to calculate what i can get it to
and all this kind of stuff right and
i've done enough research and
competitors of what features drive x
amount of traffic just looking at so
many competitors in the space so let's
say if i get it to 40
um
what is it called 40 million and what
what are the one or two things that
you'd get at the 40 million like seo
basically
so uh more seo more virality uh
increasing the quality of the templates
increasing features uh adding ai in
there like click a button we can
automatically detect backgrounds remove
it filters for social media because a
lot of people use them for social media
logo generator website as a lead gen
like that
right so then so let's say you got up to
40 million right at 40 million i can
easily monetize let's call it like
one percent of the traffic or let's get
even more conservative like a half a
percent 200 000 people
if i have 200 000 people hypothetically
paying three dollars a month okay
that's 600 000 the reason i give you on
average three dollars in certain
countries you may want to charge
different pricing like india and stuff
like that so it's more affordable so
three dollars a month and at three
dollars a month if a customer stays for
10 months that's 6 million dollars you
can probably run the thing with less
than a million million and a half and
burn each month
so then you think oh so then for a
million and a half burn you would need
once you have tons of revenue right when
you don't have tons of revenue your burn
is much lower on a monthly basis yeah
but so then how many people then if it's
you're looking at 30 people you need to
run that operation
i i don't even think 30 but let's say 30
total so i think i can actually run the
thing for under a million dollars a
month
right so i'm just trying to do the math
in my head but i mean the revenue was
like
100 million to two there
it was like 600 000 or something right
600 000 a month but if a customer stays
for 10 months you're looking at 6
million dollars
[Music]
okay if they're paying three dollars a
month if you have 4 40 million not 4
million but 40 million you're converting
a half a percent that's 200 000 paying
customers a month if they pay you three
dollars a month that's 600 000 they last
for 10 months that's six million dollars
a month in mrr over a year you're making
72 million dollars in revenue
that's crazy
[Music]
wasn't that long ago that this whole
operation was just the captain me and a
couple of parents
but hubspot helped us grow our business
across all seven seats hey celebratory
cannons
hubspot grow better